alors trouvé tout de suite non pénale et
ses bas ses mots avec et à québec et
madeleine blais morin qui était à ottawa
bonsoir à vous deux on est le 13
novembre mais on va vous parler de noël
par exemple parce que veut pas ça s'en
vient vite et je peux passer la question
que dans la tête de tout le monde est ce
que ça va être quoi noël en 2020 est ce
qu'on peut avoir le droit de voir nos
familles de recevoir nos amis est-ce
qu'ils auraient effectivement des congés
plus long où l'on sait pas trop où le
pont les enfants au québec ça prend du
sort de direction mais madeleine c'est
quand même dans un contexte où on peut
se le dire la situation est en train se
corser partout au pays
ah oui on a eu des corps record dans
plusieurs provinces pendant toute la
semaine mais parlant spécifiquement de
noël moi j'ai vu quand même un
changement de ton de justin trudeau
aujourd'hui souvenez-vous de la phrase
qu'il avait dit il ya presque un mois
quand il avait dit l'hiver un peu de
noël il va être plate désagréable à
plusieurs niveaux j'ai revérifié lorsque
j'avais tweeté à ce moment là c'est pour
ça qu'on entendait aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui disait noël va entre autres
dépendre des actions qu'on va prendre
cette fin de semaine dans les semaines à
venir donc et il essayé d'encourager les
canadiens à suivre les conseils de santé
publique en disant peut-être que noël
est encore possible d'être sauvé
probablement paul ii grand rassemblement
mais peut-être de petits rassemblements
donc il misait sur l'encouragement d'une
part et mais il misé aussi sur la craint
d'autre part et lorsqu'il a dit
aujourd'hui on pourrait atteindre dix
mille cas au début décembre le chiffre
fera non seulement le chiffre est
frappant mais si rare que le
gouvernement fait des projections comme
ça dit des chiffres comme ça avance des
données généralement s'est fait de façon
très formel présentation power point et
on monte des courbes mais là ça s'est
pas fait avec tout tout tout le support
contenant généralement mais on a cru bon
de dire ce chiffre là aujourd'hui parce
que la situation est quand même assez
mais finalement c'est comme si on
cherchait la bonne façon de passer le
message comme si on sentait qu'on
l'avait pas trouvé encore mais qu'il
fallait changer la façon et encore une
fois je sais que christian noël notre
collègue en a parlé tout à l'heure mais
il ya eu ces nouvelles publicités si qui
ont été rendus publics
jusqu'à maintenant on avait des
publicités qui était très très formelle
d administrateur en chef de la santé
publique on voyait le docteur new entre
autres sur nos réseaux de télévision qui
de façon très formel encore une fois dix
ans de suivre les conseils de santé
publique on les voit ses publicités là
en ce moment à l'écran en disant
continuer de suivre les conseils de
santé publique les mesures de santé
publique et vous verrez un jour on va
s'en sortir
un jour on pourra assister à des
mariages donc là encore une fois comme
tout à l'heure lorsque je parlais de
l'encouragement de noël c'est un pull
encouragements de dire on va y arriver
on sentait que les gens avaient besoin
d'un peu d'espoir parce qu'on dit à quel
point les gens sont en dessous les gens
sont déprimés y en a qui vont pas bien
du tout géré à chaque citoyen reçoit ces
informations là à sa manière c'est pas
tout le monde qui est capable de dire
europe tout va bien sébastien est un peu
la même chose d'ailleurs au québec
le discours de monsieur legault au début
c'était on va sauver noël pile on a
l'impression que le 1er mai c'est lui
qui est en train de sexe ça va être un
petit peu modeste mettons web est un peu
un message d'espoir mais de peur aussi
légèrement la balle au bond de justin
trudeau se dire qu'il faut une dose de
peur pour pouvoir appliquer les mesures
seigneur pour vous nous rappeler qu'il
faut appliquer les mesures syndication
veut avoir un noël
même modeste donc si on a peur de la
commune on applique les mesures
sanitaires le nombre de cas diminue qui
on est capable d'avoir des
rassemblements donc on essaie de nous
dit c'est la carotte et le bâton le
bateau c'est la peur de pas avoir de
dalby la carotte c'est l'espoir de voir
dell
donc si notre site tenait qu'à françois
legault dans son for intérieur il
souhaiterait que les québécois puissent
passer noël en famille peut-être deux
ménages de deux adresses différentes qui
pourraient se rassembler donc de petits
rassemblements mais la santé publique
pour l'instant est pas branché on sait
pas avec la tendance actuelle si c'est
une bonne idée de permettre aux gens de
se rassembler parce que rappelez-vous
depuis démons nous dit le problème ce
sont les rassemblements alors pourquoi
on a permettrait dans le contexte actuel
à noël
si ce n'est pas pour nous donner un peu
d'espoir est un petit robot dans cette
lutte mais dans la vraie vie sébastien
le avait beau interdire aux gens des
rassemblements
on se doute bien qu'il ya des gens qui
vont le faire quand même est-ce qu'on
peut imaginer des policiers partout qui
connut en v en sort de noël la question
la question a été posée à aura sûrement
un goût d'un point presse on lui a
demandé vous monsieur arruda vous avez
trois enfants voilà on a invité justin l
vous invitez et kehl
alors c'est des choix déchirants ci ont
respecté les règles
l'autre côté c'est à dire probablement
qu'il ya plusieurs personnes qui ne
respecteront pas à la lettre on peut
respecter un peu l'esprit de la règle
mais n'est pas nécessairement à la
lettre la règle et ça le gouvernement en
est conscient avec les dangers que ça
compte
et puis depuis le début de la pandémie
la santé publique doit et la politique
aussi doivent considérer la balance des
inconvénients
évidemment on pourrait qu'on finit tout
le monde puis le virus disparaîtrait
plus rapidement ou on pourrait la
contrôler cette courbe là mais il ya
toutes sortes de facteurs qu'il faut
considérer est le facteur de santé
mentale il est important mais aussi et
noël c'est important dans notre santé
mentale collective j'imagine alors ça
fait partie des calculs qui doivent être
faits on n'est pas des gens qui sont
complètement cartésien tout le temps la
magie de noël les élus et puis pour des
personnes âgées parfois c'est seul
moment dans l'année où ils vont pas
avoir accès à leurs familles font et il
ya des personnes pour qui on sait ça va
être la dernière occasion d'être avec
notre mère parce qu'elle est âgée elle
est malade alors ya toutes sortes de
considérations comme ceux qui sont
extrêmement sensibles pour tout le monde
finalement noël et les écoles sont aussi
c'est tout un casse tête sébastien alors
on voit monsieur robert je le ministre
de l'éducation au québec on a
l'impression qu'ils aient toujours un
arrière du stress on al'impression
monsieur legault est loin en avant que
monsieur ce but la santé est loin en
avant et que lui [ __ ] fort pour
essayer de rejoindre le haut niveau
d'information et leur message séparé mal
en ce moment parce que le ministère
d'éducation le ministre roberge est sous
pression sous pression pour l'aération
des classes si une chose qu'on pouvait
prévoir 2020 une chose c'est que l'hiver
arriverait un jour on pourrait peut-être
avoir des enfants dans les cases qui
aurait besoin donc de faire aérer leur
classe leur monsieur robert dutil
depuis le mois de juin ou juillet on
demande un état des lieux sur la
ventilation des écoles on
au monde devant moi ça se fait qu'on n'a
pas encore l'état des lieux donc
première chose
ensuite le ms recommande de réduire la
taille des classes des groupes classes
dans les écoles
c'est avec peut-être la moitié de la
classe physiquement dans la classe dans
l'école puis l'autre moitié qui suit le
cours à distance on au gouvernement nous
accord a commencé par nous dire c'est
pas possible parce que si on fait ça
faut doubler le nombre de classes faut
doubler nombre de profs non il ya des
écoles qui n'ont fait pis qui ont la
moitié de la classe en classe puis la
moitié de la classe et à la maison et ça
marche pourvu qu on n'apprivoise la
technologie pourvu que les profs soient
d'accord
il a beaucoup de profs sont d'accord
pour faire cet effort là les élèves
aussi alors en effet on a l'impression
que des fois monsieur roberge et deux
pas en arrière
est-ce que c'est sa machine qu'ils
placent deux pas en arrière malgré tout
la volonté politique qu'il peut avoir
disons qu'on se pose des questions par
les temps qui courent oui puis madeleine
sur cette question de gouttelettes qui
peuvent se transmettent sur le fort
microscopique là en aérosol c'est comme
si au québec on venait d'allumer que ça
peut être une donnée importante
alors monsieur dubé a même mandaté un
comité d'experts pour se pencher là
dessus
pourtant il me semble que j'ai déjà
entendu un point de presse avec madame
tam avec son adjoint et il avait
présenté déjà c'est de donner l'un est
pour eux c'était déjà du sérieux c'est
du sérieux mais ça reste une donnée si
je ne me trompe je suis pas une experte
scientifique mais qui est discuté encore
une fois dans la communauté scientifique
mais ça reste effectivement quand on en
discute
il faut aussi en discuter d'un point de
vue politique pour savoir quelles sont
les conséquences
par exemple si on convient finalement
que la transmission par aérosol est
importante donc qu'est ce qu'on fait
avec cette nouvelle donne est là et la
préparation elle est importante c'est
certes un bon pour revenir sur la
ventilation vous avez mentionné quelque
chose qui étonne un peu tout le monde
dit on sait quel point ils ont été
nombreux les journalistes de tous médias
confondus à essayer d'avoir plus
d'informations sur c'est quoi le
portrait réel de portraits des problèmes
de ventilation des besoins de
ventilation dans les écoles mais
finalement on se rend compte pour nous
tous chercher de notre côté mais le
portrait personne ne l'a actuellement
j'ai rendu qu'on a des collègues postés
dans le devoir ce matin devant leur
propre gré c'est-à-dire qu'ils demandent
à des proches d'eux
la qualité de l'air dans leur classe
puis on s'aperçoit que certains
problèmes de ventilation le gouvernement
en fait l'histoire des aérosols
l'histoire du danger des petites
gouttelettes qui reste dans l'air par
exemple dans une classe d'école ça a été
énoncée à partir du mois de juin juillet
au milieu de l'été donne alors le
gouvernement
on a demandé un état des lieux le
problème c'est que c'était un des lieux
n'est pas encore fait on se demande
combien d'écoles combien de khl ans
aurait besoin de systèmes de ventilation
puis pendant ce temps laisse que
l'opposition dit c'est que en allemagne
on achète des purificateurs d'air ou des
ventilateurs dans l'état de new york ont
fait la même chose dans qu on a qui sont
déjà en mouvement là dessus pourquoi on
n'est pas au québec
en même temps sur ben j'ai peut-être un
point en dix ans et les centres de
services scolaires née d'une nouvelle
commission scolaire au niveau local qui
on a déterminé c'est quoi à leurs
besoins le problème c'est qu'on ne sait
pas c'est quoi les besoins en ce moment
et on peut présumer qu au mois de
novembre
on aurait dû savoir c'était quoi les
goûts oui mais c'est quand même lui le
patron des centres de santé scolaire
c'est lui le patron et en même temps si
on veut décentraliser le ministre de
l'éducation il peut pas prendre toutes
les décisions mur à mur dans toutes les
écoles ça c'est un coin quand on peut
saisir mais il faut qu'ils fassent
preuve de leadership il faut qu'ils
mettent de la pression il faut qu'il est
qu'il se contente pas d'une réponse
le rapport va venir la semaine prochaine
faut qu'ils relancent faut qu'ils
demandent des comptes à ceux qui sont
imputables en réjouissent que c'est ça
son roulis peut pas tout et dictée parce
qu'il connaît manche et la réalité de
chacune des écoles mais ils doivent
certainement assumer ce leadership et de
mettre de la pression sur son réseau
pour que le réseau livre quelques jours
bon parlons maintenant d'un autre
dossier on se rappelle hier québec qui
présentait sa mise à jour économique
avec le ministre girard il a essayé
d'expliquer son plan de relance
ça vaut bien les finances du québec
savent où provient des finances de
personnes de toute façon en ce moment
mais un de ses piliers pour la relance
est basé sur ottawa ans c'est avec cette
volonté qu'ottawa augmenterait de
beaucoup d'ailleurs ces transferts en
santé pas juste j'osais d'une fois mais
je le fais et ça devient récurrent ça
devient la norme
alors il a présenté sawyer mais par la
suite madeleine il y avait une rencontre
entre monsieur trudeau et ses homologues
provinciaux est ce qu'une en a été
question hier soir ah oui on est souvent
question de ces transferts en santé
c'est la 21e rang quand on trie hier au
téléphone depuis le début de la pandémie
et encore une fois les provinces on dit
il faut augmenter la part des transferts
en santé le gouvernement fédéral s'était
engagé à voir une rencontre pour
discuter de ça et
encore hier il y eut on aurait été ré
l'engagement justin trudeau a dit il va
y avoir une rencontre cette rencontre
leur va se tenir
je pense en partie virtuelle de façon
virtuelle au début décembre
mais ça c'est une chose de dire on va en
parler
le fait de dire on va augmenter les
transferts il ya quand même un gros porc
qui doit être franchie et justin trudeau
ans aujourd'hui en point de presse
semblait dire bon on va en discuter puis
on va voir ce que ça va donner
sans beaucoup s'engager à augmenter de
façon récurrente les transferts j'ai
l'impression qu'il va falloir un moment
donné qu'il fasse un bout de chemin
mais le bout de chemin que demandent les
provinces c'est quand même assez
important en ce moment le gouvernement
fédéral finance environ 20 22% des coûts
en santé alors que les provinces 78%
donc les provinces voudrait que le
gouvernement fédéral augmente sa part à
35 % ce qui est quand même un bond
substantiel
oui ça se présente comment parce que
c'est monsieur legault sébastien qui va
lors de cette prochaine rencontre pour
parler des transferts en santé qui va
présider finalement cette cette réunion
là lui le besoin d'alliés il n'a besoin
que les autres provinces par dans le
même sens que d'huile oui il a besoin de
maintenir je prends comment il est
président de ce qu'on appelle le conseil
de la fédération aussi à la réunion donc
de tous les premiers ministres du pays
donc c'est lui qui est le porte drapeau
si on veut pour pour cette cause là le
gouvernement terral parfois pris un à un
les premiers ministres pour leur dire
mais regarde si tu me donnes ça je te
donne est simple et frites et donc je
front commun pour l'instant le front
commun a l'air de tenir mais la somme
que les provinces demande est énorme 28
milliards de plus de financement de la
santé par année mais justin trudeau
jusqu'à maintenant il a dit on a donné
une aide ponctuelle il n'a pas démontré
beaucoup d'ouverture à cette demande là
mais en même temps il a dit nous serons
là pour les canadiens alors qu'est ce
que ça veut dire au delà de cette phrase
un peu creuse
est ce que ça veut dire qu'il est prêt à
mettre d'argent est ce que ça veut dire
qu'il est prêt à mettre d'argent mais
peut-être à des conditions il a parlé de
normes nationales pour les chs ld pour
s'assurer qu'on a les mêmes normes à
travers le pays
ce que ça pourrait être une monnaie des
changes ici à québec on est très
réfractaire à cette possibilité là on
veut l'argent mais on veut pour en faire
ce qu'on veut avec l'argent pour
l'investir au centre bon en même temps
ça semble pas être la priorité du
gouvernement fédéral en ce moment oui je
peux en parler mais la priorité c'est de
jeu
la pandémie pas nécessairement d'établir
une nouvelle formule de financement à
plus long terme ces projets se servent
de la pandémie pour obtenir plus
d'argent pour financer leur santé en
disant notre réseau de la santé fragile
regardez ce qui s'est passé avec la
corée du sud alors on ne l'a même
pandémie et deux types d'arguments
complètement contre contraire mais je
vous laisse maintenant avec une dernière
question à ce qu'un fédéral les moyens
aussi dont citant ce transfert madeleine
bien en ce moment le gouvernement
fédéral a les moyens de dépenser pas mal
mais le rezidor le directeur
parlementaire du budget disait à ce
rythme là c'est pas soutenable donc ça
c'est oui peut-être un an peut-être deux
ans mais on peut pas on peut pas
maintenir ce rythme de dépenses là
évidemment mais j'ai l'impression
on verra bien bon alors donc la remporte
elle aurait lieu dans les premiers jours
de décembre c'est ça la surveiller mais
écoutez c'est là dessus qu'on va se
laisser à on va essayer de fabriquer
personnellement ce nom scénario de
troubles et de noël possible
merci beaucoup peint semaine à vous deux
records au revoir
[Musique]